if you've seen the Twitter files
what have you learned from
the kind of uh pressure from U.S
government agencies that was seen in
Twitter files and what do you do with
that kind of pressure
you know I've I've seen it
um
it's really hard from the outside to
know exactly what happened in each of
these cases you know we've we've
obviously been
been in a bunch of our own cases where
you know where
agencies or different folks will just
say hey
here's a threat that we're aware of
you should be aware of this too it's not
really pressure as much as it is just
um
you know flagging something that that
our our security systems should be on on
alert about
I I get how some people could think of
it as that
um but at the end of the day it's our
it's our call on how to on on how to
handle that but I mean I I just you know
in terms of running these Services won't
have access to as much information about
what people think that adversaries might
be trying to do as possible boy so you
don't feel
like there will be consequences if uh
you know anybody the CIA the FBI a
political party the Democrats of the
Republicans of high
powerful political figures write emails
you don't feel pressure from
I guess what I say is there's so much
pressure from all sides then I'm not
sure that any specific thing that
someone says is really adding that much
more to the mix it's um there are
obviously a lot of people who think that
um that we should be censoring more
content or there are a lot of people who
think we should be censoring less
content there are as you say all kinds
of different groups that are involved in
these debates right so there's the kind
of elected officials and politicians
themselves there's the agencies but but
I mean but there's the the media there's
activist groups there's
um this is not a U.S specific thing
there are groups all over the world and
and kind of all
um in every country that that bring
different values
um
so it's just a very it's a very active
debate and I and I understand it right I
mean these are you know these these kind
of
questions get to really some of the most
important social debates that that are
that are being had so
um it gets back to the question of truth
because
for a lot of these things they haven't
yet been hardened into a single truth
and
um society's sort of trying to hash out
what
um you know what we think right on on on
certain issues maybe in a few hundred
years everyone will look back and say
hey no it wasn't it obvious that it
should have been this but you know no
we're we're kind of in the in that meat
grinder now and you know and and
working through that so
um
so no these are these are all are all
very complicated and
you know some people
raise concerns in good faith and just
say hey this is something I want to flag
for you to think about
certain people I I certainly think like
come at things with someone of a more
kind of punitive or
vengeful view of like I like I want you
to do this thing if you don't then I'm
going to try to make your life difficult
and in a lot of other ways but like
I don't know there's just this is like
this is one of the most pressurized
debates I think in society so I just
think that there are so many people on
different forces that are trying to
apply pressure from different sides that
it's I I don't think you can make
decisions based on trying to make people
happy I think you just have to do what
you think is the right balance and
accept that people are going to be upset
no matter where you come out on that
yeah I like that pressurized debate uh
so how is your view of the freedom of
speech evolved over the years
um
and now with AI
where the freedom might apply to them
not just to the humans but to the uh the
personalized agents as you've spoken
about them
so yeah I mean I've probably gotten to
someone more nuanced view just because I
think that there are you know I come at
this I'm obviously very Pro
freedom of expression right I don't
think you build a service like this that
gives people tools to express themselves
unless you think that people expressing
themselves at scale is a good thing
right so I I get into this to like try
to prevent people from from expressing
anything I like want to give people
tools so they can express as much as
possible and then I think
it's become clear that there are certain
categories of things that we've talked
about
that I think almost everyone accepts or
are bad and that no one wants and that
they're that are illegal even in
countries like the US where you know you
have the the First Amendment that's very
protective of of enabling speech it's
like you're still not allowed to you
know do things that are going to
immediately inside violence or you know
violate people's intellectual property
or things like that so through those but
then there's also a very active core of
just active disagreements in society
where some people may think that
something is true or false the other
side might think it's
the opposite or just unsettled right and
um and those are some of the most
difficult to to kind of handle like like
we've talked about
but
um
one of the lessons that I feel like I've
learned is that
a lot of times
when you can
the best way to handle this stuff
more practically is not in terms of
answering the question of should this be
allowed but just like
what
what is the best way to deal with
someone being a jerk
is the person basically just having a
like repeat
behavior of like
causing a lot of a lot of issues
um so looking at it more at that level
and its effect on the broader
community's Health the community health
yeah
It's Tricky though because like how do
you know there could be people
that have a very controversial Viewpoint
that turns out to have a positive
long-term effect on the health of the
community because it challenges the
community that's true absolutely as yeah
I think you and I think you want to be
careful about that I'm not sure I'm
expressing this very very clearly
um
because I certainly agree with your your
point there and my point isn't that we
should
not have people on our services that are
that are that are being controversial
that's that's certainly not what I mean
to say
um it's that often I think
it's not just looking at a specific
example of speech that it's most
effective to to handle this stuff
um and and I I think often you don't
want to make specific binary decisions
of kind of this is allowed or this isn't
I mean we talked about you know it's
fact checking or Twitter's Community
Voices thing I think that's another good
example it's like it's not a question of
is this allowed or not it's just a
question of adding more context to the
thing I think that that's helpful